it's been a long time love Jolin
now let's see
the last time we met I saved your soul
now there's something you can do for me
look I'd love to help but your timing
mister but this won't take long you see
there's a demon eye where its possessing
a little girl not demon he knows your
name
[Music]
this is John Constantine skinny Britnie
trenchcoat I'm gonna clean traced
warlock expert on the occult
they tell you don't like horror movies
welcome to the Waverider Wally West
next time Vietnam crappy war bitching
music where is Grodd who are you
but who needs a lumbering tin can when
you can time-travel with a single
thought
everybody we got some new legends of
tomorrow to break down obviously there's
a Constantine stuff that's coming up
first then we have Wally West they've
finally made it official like they
released that promo we have a special
message for Wally West you know welcome
aboard to the Waverider so we know
everybody's wondering about the Wally
stuff but in the back of everyone's
minds they're thinking Constantine as a
permanent member of the Waverider I'll
try to address that too because I think
their plans have changed in a good way
because of what's going on with DC
movies right now there's a new round of
the flash ring giveaway - all you have
to do to enter just be a subscriber and
share the video using those tools on the
watch page originally I think the
character was earmarked for Justice
League dark but that sort of in
development hell right now and there's
like a number of DC movies that they've
confirmed her being made Justice League
dark is one of those movies that's
having problems locking down a director
like they had doug liman for a little
while then he had to leave because of
scheduling problems so because we don't
know when that's going to come it just
frees up the Constantine character like
oh if you're not going to be doing it
for a couple more years then it's
totally okay to do them on the TV shows
but that was really weird when it comes
to explaining stuff like that because
the producers want to be nice to the
studio because the studio controls the
characters the producers have to ask
permission when they want to use them
like right now Deathstroke is off limits
so for the most part I think they're
free and clear to use Constantine as
much as they want but it really just
depends on the story that they're doing
so I think that all this stuff has to be
decided so far in advance that for the
time being Constantine will just be
around for these two episodes when
Legends comes back February 12th so just
another reminder I'm probably have to
say it a couple more times before we get
there but Legends is going to be a
Monday night show it'll air in the
Supergirl timeslot starting February
12th at 8 p.m. it just air the rest of
the episodes for legends of tomorrow
season then after the legends finale
Supergirl will retake that time slot and
air the rest of its season it sounds
weirder than it actually is but it's
partially meant to address some
production issues they had behind the
scenes some delays that they had and
also according to the president of the
network the idea that there might be too
many shows at once like you throw too
much of people and they'll just start
tuning out and they want everybody to
get on Black Lightning because it's the
brand-new show so if you throw too much
of people they're less likely to watch
that extra
new show but jumping back to wally west
officially confirmed as a new character
so when legends comes back episode 10
episode 11 will be the two-part
constatine story he'll go away
then they'll create the need for wally
west like they have to have a reason for
him to need to be on the Waverider
that'll be episode 12 then at the end of
that episode he'll show up and be on the
Waverider from episode 13 on for the
most part but based on the fact that
legends only has 18 episodes I actually
used to think that he was gonna jump
back before the legends finale but I
actually looked at the timeline for when
the episodes are actually going to air
the legends finale will air with a
couple weeks to spare for the last
couple of episodes of the flash so he
could actually still be there and help
them with their malice problem and then
go back to the flash for like the last
two or three episodes even if Wally
doesn't come back till flash episode 22
and then he's there for 22 and 23
it'll still be fine the actors like yeah
I'm always gonna be a flash character
he's one of the flashes eventually
someday in the future of the story of
the show he becomes the main version of
the flash but because they have so many
characters there's just no way that they
can do all them surface so when you have
a situation on Legends where you lose a
couple cast members at the same time
boom just send them over there it'll be
great you can do that with almost any of
the characters on any of the shows
depending on how their personality fits
with the group and the story that
they're doing so the cool thing about
that though the Wally going on legends
like they wouldn't just put him there
because it's a cool idea they're
actually trying to use them in a really
constructive way
where is Grodd
but who needs a lumbering tin can when
you can time travel with a single
thought
so doesn't it make so much more sense
now why they would grab Wally if Grodd
is such a big deal on legends of
tomorrow you get a flash villain you get
a flash speedster to help take him down
so the obviously malice is the big
villain and we still don't have enough
information about who he is yet he still
sounds like this Barbados Dark Knight's
metal type villain like someone who
exists beyond the known universe or
somewhere between the cracks in the
universe he's some sort of crazy
supernatural spirit like people have
theorized that he's a version of the
reverse-flash that died last season I
don't think that's the case because Matt
ledger was also like yeah you know if
the flash comes back to the flash TV
show this year he's not gonna be me
he absolutely confirmed that it will be
a different face but we can talk about
reverse flash stuff during another flash
video that doesn't have really anything
to do with what's going on with Wally on
legends I don't think that it's going to
be any kind of flash fill and I think it
will wind up being something to do with
the time Bureau because they just seemed
like the big antagonists this season and
what bigger surprise and the people who
look like they're trying to fix things
wind up being the true villain of the
series it's still a little too early to
guess who malice is I think we need a
couple more episodes but they will start
giving us more clues when the show comes
back so no worries there but what I'm
hoping is is that when Wally goes back
to the flash that even you know even if
they use him for some big flash story
the first half of season 5 they still
leave room for him to go back on legends
for at least a couple episodes next
season assuming that legends gets
renewed which I think that it will I
don't think there's gonna be any
problems with that but also that they
use this Constantine two-part episode is
a dry run to see how he fits how
everybody likes him and then just bring
him back is a series regular next season
so like one of the big problems that I
feel like Legends has had the past
couple seasons is with its roster of
characters like at any given time
there's at least one really cool
character but there's so many characters
on that show that you really need to
have at least like half of them be
pretty big a-list characters in order to
make the series interesting so people
like Constantine that aren't being used
anywhere people like Wally West that are
riding the bench on his own TV show in
the flash it just makes sense that you
would try to use them even more and if
arrow goes off the air in a couple
seasons you can even send some of those
characters onto legends of
in a future season but I actually do
think that arrow is gonna get a season
seven so I don't think it's gonna be an
issue next year but that also kind of
reminds me we actually haven't gotten
official renewals from the CW on any of
the DC TV shows although they have said
they're pretty optimistic that
everybody's getting renewed and I think
that everybody feels like everyone's
getting renewed it's more of a question
how much longer they're gonna do shows
that aren't getting quite as good
ratings like arrow isn't getting great
ratings right now even though a lot of
people are watching it online and
supergirls ratings are declining a
little bit so early prediction is that
they're in season three of Supergirl
right now Supergirl makes it to five
seasons and they just wrap it at that
unless they have some dramatic
turnaround in their ratings arrow goes
to seven seasons and they also wrap at
that unless it has a dramatic turnaround
in ratings and then the same thing
happens with legends but a lot of that
just depends on how many new shows they
have coming in to replace them so one of
the reasons why I think that arrow might
not make it past seven seasons is
because Black Lightning has had such a
strong start if it continues to do
really well in the ratings I think that
it will be the replacement for arrow
because it serves that sort of dark
gritty real world city based TV show but
it's too soon to tell and most of these
TV shows make more money on the
syndication and output deals that they
have with other networks than they do on
the advertising they do on the new
episodes that they air week to week
which sounds kind of weird but it's the
reason why the CW doesn't worry so much
about week to week ratings the same way
that major networks do well let me know
in the comments do you want Constantine
to be a series regular next season and
what do you want them to do with Wally
West on the flash or on legends what'll
happen next is to have new Game of
Thrones to post maybe some new marvel of
DC congratulations to the winner from my
Don Allen giveaway Ken Bolden please
private message me so I can get your
contact details click here to rewatch
that Don Allen iris west speedster video
and click here for that brand new Black
Panther Avengers trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight